Attorney General Jeff Sessions testified  in front of the Senate Intelligence  Committee and I gotta tell you I watched  the entire testimony I'm sure you did  too I noticed something that was kind of  interesting sessions has a nervous tic  no no if you saw this almost like a  poker tell that comes out at times when  he may be lying and if you look really  closely you might even see it  take a look I would have gladly have  reported the meeting the encounter that  may have occurred that some say occurred  in the Mayflower if I had remembered it  or if it actually occurred which I don't  remember that it did never remember  having a conversation or meeting with a  master kiss Leah I do not people are  suggesting through innuendo that I have  been not honest about matters and I've  tried to be honest  [Applause]  you